est il responsable d'alléger les mesures
de restriction à partir du mois prochain
une question légitime qui s'invite dans
les débats ces derniers jours alors que
le chef de l'état prévoit de lever les
contraintes à travers une succession
d'étapes pour cela l'exécutif compte sur
la décrue du nombre de contaminations
amorcé ces derniers temps la situation
elle est sous contrôle dans la mesure où
vous le savez aujourd'hui à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle
l'épidémie a plutôt tendance à régresser
elle ne régresse pas aussi vite que je
souhaiterais qu'elle régresse et que les
français le souhaiterait évidemment mais
nous sommes passés de quelques quarante
mille cas diagnostiqués par jour à un
petit peu moins de 30000 casquette
encore un haut niveau de circulation du
virus
ceux qui appliquent eux nous devons
encore poursuivre nos efforts notamment
dans la lutte contre la diffusion de ces
variants qui on le sait sont plus
contagieux une tendance à la baisse qui
pourrait s'appliquer aussi dans les
services de réanimation
reste que pour l'heure les indicateurs
restent particulièrement élevé la barre
des 6000 patients qu'aux vide en soins
critiques étaient atteintes ce lundi un
chiffre qui témoigne d'une tension
hospitalière encore très soutenue au
bout de la chaîne
l'effet domino est bien visible les
équipes chirurgicales devront dès que
possible et rattraper le retard accumulé
du fait des déprogrammations
d'opérations non urgentes
un levier qui permet de libérer des lits
et du personnel médical
à ce jour nous sommes à peu près à 60%
de déprogrammation par rapport à notre
activité normale
bien sûr ça induit des tours
le gros problème des gros problèmes
organisationnels au sein de l'hôpital
beaucoup de frustration dans les équipes
chirurgicale donc vous dire que c'est
tenable
oui de toute façon nous n'avons pas le
n'avons pas le choix
notre objectif est de reprendre les plus
rapidement possible une activité normale
tout en conservant deux missions de
service public qui sont de prendre en
charge les patients malades du code vide
quoi qu'il en soit les français
attendent désormais que le fou se
disperse autour du calendrier des
réouvertures qui devrait bel et bien se
faire en ordre dispersé